hello
and welcome everyone to pi data boston's
december meetup
for those of you who don't know pi data
is an educational program of a
non-profit organization called num focus
the global pi data network promotes
discussion of best practices
new approaches and emerging technologies
for data management
processing analytics and visualization
we are a community of users and
developers of open source data
analysis tools and this meetup is a form
for us to share ideas and learn from
each other
we also approach data science using many
languages including
but not limited to pokemon julia and r
my name is anina yip and i'm one of the
co-organizers of pi data boston
i'm really thrilled to have two
presenters for you tonight
first we'll hear from stanley zheng
providing a comprehensive guide on the
applications of pseudo-labeling and how
he won a kaggle medal using only
pseudo-labeling
afterwards karini khannan will go
through topic modeling for
data discovery and focus in on a cyber
security use case
now before we get to them i want to
touch base on a few items
first feel free to introduce yourselves
in the chat and in slack
where there's also an introductions
channel as we continue to hold virtual
events we want to continue building our
community and of course if you have
questions during the presentation
please unmute yourself and chime in for
a real-time conversation
and for those of you who aren't speaking
just please make sure to turn off your
microphone
and we have our uh website up at
boston.highdata.org
and on social media feel free to tweet
about today's talk using hashtag
boss and if you haven't joined our slack
community yet please do
this information is also on our meetup
page
as of all meetings we want to reiterate
that pi data is dedicated to providing a
harassment free event experience for
everyone
please behave professionally as we do
not tolerate harassment in any form
you can view the longer version of our
code for conduct at this website
so feel free to reach out to any of the
organizers or concerns
thank you again for helping to make this
a welcoming friendly community for all
and lastly these meetings are only made
possible with the help of volunteers
you can do anything from organizing an
event by recruiting speakers to creating
partnerships
or we're back to meeting in person you
might also help secure venues and food
what's more we have an ongoing need for
speakers
please consider volunteering to present
and speak at one of our meetings
you don't have to have a full talk ready
when you fill out the speaker form as
the organizing team can help
you through that and in fact harini was
someone who filled out our speaker form
so i'm excited that we were able to
connect and have her present tonight
we're really in for a treat from both
speakers and with that
i will turn it over to stanley
okay
okay a guide to pseudo labeling how to
get a kegel medal with only one model
privacy has been a hot topic on the news
whether this be a smart speaker
recording constantly or a social media
app turning on your camera in the
background
with this comes the question where does
all of this data go
there are thousands of hours of
recording and that
can't really be hand labeled for amazon
alexa and possibly
hundreds of other companies all of this
data is pseudo-labeled
according to a blog post in april amazon
uses this technique to help alexa match
skills to customer requests
and this technique pseudo-labeling is a
topic of today's talk
a bit about me i'm stanley a student at
athabasca university from alberta canada
i love the field of data science and
machine learning i'm a cagler and my
interests include photography
computer vision and fintech i'm an open
source contributor on a few
repos on github as well as a few
hackathons which is where i'm at anita
you can find me on github kaggle
linkedin and devpost as at stanley
jaisang
in my first kaggle competition in june i
placed 73rd out of 2245 competitors
which is in the top three percent the
catch is that i achieved this in two
weeks using one model while most if not
all top teams used an ensemble of two to
five models
and had a period of three months today's
talk is about some of the tips and
tricks i've learned
a guide including validation techniques
examples
when to apply pseudo labels and when not
to
first we'll talk about what pseudolabels
are and how and why anyone would ever
use them
next we will talk about how to
effectively use suitable labels
including training and validation
schemes thirdly we will talk about
applications
specifically a few kaggle competitions
and the previous
of their image classification model on
imagenet and finally i have a simple
demo in tensorflow and keras on
the mnist data set i'll mostly be
discussing the application to neural
networks in deep learning today
or machine learning in general and i've
created a small
list of further reading and references
in the github repo which you can find at
bit.ly slash pi data github this link
can be found in the bottom left corner
of every slide and the slides are also
uploaded there
a special thanks to johan babakin for
providing some of the graphics and
results of pseudo-labeling from
competitions
his paper titled semi-supervised
supplementation of cell body of seismic
images using an ensemble of
convolutional neural networks
is referenced in the github and provides
an excellent look into the full process
of a winning
team in a casual competition including
pseudolabel
let's begin by exploring what pseudo
labels are pseudo-labels are a form of
semi-supervised learning
semi-supervised learning means that you
can leverage a small labeled trained
data set
and a large unlabeled data set
semi-supervised learning takes elements
from unsupervised learning
and supervised learning yeah some
techniques that fall under this umbrella
include adversarial methods but
data labeling is the most simple and the
subject of this talk
so what is pseudolabeling and how do you
use it the basic ideas of
pseudo-labeling are quite simple
first we train a model on our label
train data this is the supervised
learning part
then we infer on the unlabeled data
these inferred labels are now called
pseudolabels
now after merging the original labels
alongside our suited labels
we can retrain the model or train a
different model on the new set
containing pseudolabels this is
unsupervised learning
in this way your training data is not
only your label data
but also your unlabeled data when i
learned this technique it was quite
unintuitive since the model made the
predictions that were used to train
itself
doesn't already know the information and
when this propagate error
we reinforce class imbalance and overfit
however through training augmentations
and dropout the pseudo-label model will
almost always outperform a model without
pseudo-labeling and is probably more
robust also
here's a graphic to demonstrate this is
a simple classification problem
between the blue squares and green
triangles with label data we can just
draw a decision boundary
with supervised learning and classify
them based on the labels
next we can introduce some unlabeled
test data let's say
red circles however if we were to just
use this model with our decision
boundary
we would cut through some of the red
circles and it'd be incorrect
so this is where we can label the red
circles and we can sue to label the red
circles
so that we are training on the red
circles and so our final model would be
something along the lines of this with
pseudo-labeling we can also utilize the
unlabeled data
shown in red circles though we did not
change the label data we can see that
with the introduction of the unlabeled
data
our final model is significantly
different more robust and more
representative
the introduction of the unlabeled data
has positively changed the way our model
performs
so why would you want to use
pseudo-labels in the real world there's
a few reasons
firstly data is expensive to label
either difficult to obtain
or difficult to label without a large
workforce for example you're labeling
hundreds of heads of wheat in one image
so it's infeasible to hand label all of
them or maybe you're classifying ct
scans and need a domain expert or
radiologist to label it for you
another reason is that data is time
consuming to obtain or
label models need to be made soon but
time is needed to build the training set
and label it alternatively data needs to
be sorted to be used
the data diversity could also be
inadequate for example if we are taking
images
the training images could be from one
location and the test location with
different lighting
species or something along those lines
and really
pseudo labeling can be applied to any
application where there is very little
trained data
but a lot of unlabeled test data
comparatively so that we can leverage
this test sets for better performance
uh an example of this would be the
imagenet data set where 14 million
images were assembled and hand labeled
in over
1 000 in 1 000 classes and it took seven
years to construct
however 350 million photos are uploaded
daily to facebook
weekly sorted by hashtags according to a
white paper and by facebook in 2013.
these images are probably more diverse
than any pre-made data sets
and if we can effectively leverage these
massive amounts of data
then our models will perform
significantly better
so that's the basic idea of pseudolabels
and while the general idea is quite
simple there's a wide variety of popular
implementations
i'll discuss some of these popular
implementation techniques for
training first and then validation and
some general tips for successful
implementation
training has a few popular schemes all
of these start the same way we train a
model on the label data and then in
first pseudo labels
but the way the pseudo labels are
trained on differs
first we have the most simple
self-training in self-training a model
which is already trained on label data
is then used to infer on unlabeled data
then fine-tunes itself with
pseudo-labels that it itself creates
this is usually the least performant
method to train pseudo labels but is by
far the simplest
only requiring one single model and some
copy pasting of inference training code
this scheme also sometimes propagates
error and is
usually sensitive to hyper parameters
compared to the others
our second method is simultaneous
training simultaneous training is when
pseudo labels are mixed with labeled
data then trained simultaneously
so the full end to end would be we train
a model on the label data
to produce sudo labels and then we can
combine the label data with the pseudo
labels
to form a larger label data set which we
then train a new model on
the model that is trained can either be
imagenet pre-trained
and then fine-tuned in the new combined
data or model initialize from scratch
however with this model sorry with this
method you may want to
train from scratch rather our third
method is to pre-train the model on
pseudolabels alone
so after obtaining pseudo-labels from
your original model trained on
labeled trained data instead of using
pre-trained weights from say imagenet
or other pre-trained weights we train
our model
and pre-train it on pseudo-labels so
and the idea behind this is that the
weights from the model trained on
pseudo labels are going to be much more
representative than the actual
pre-trained weights from imagenet
and this method is described more in a
paper titled native semi-supervised deep
learning using
pseudolabel where the authors achieved
significant performance improvements
using pre-training with pseudo-labels
compared to an imagenet weights
initialization
this is an extremely impressive
technique in which with only 100
training samples
the mnist model their mnist model
achieves 75.5
accuracy on 28 000 image test set which
is
well yeah with only 100 training samples
there's also a few things to keep in
mind with pseudolabels these are a few
guidelines that i've picked up
and are shared around kaggle and
sometimes around papers firstly
pseudolabels need to apply
be applied to data which is at least
somewhat representative of your label
train data
if your model encounters an edge case or
out of domain data which is not
addressed by training data
it's not likely to guess correctly so
your pseudo labels are of low quality
and noisy
however if your data contains a
reasonable number of out of domain
elements
you may be able to filter it through
confidence for example
you may only choose a pseudo label if
one class is over 80 certain
so out of domain data is hopefully
excluded from your pseudo labels
in general your pseudo labels will be
more effective if you filter pseudo
labels to confident predictions only
secondly soft pseudo labels almost
always perform better than hard pseudo
labels
hard pseudo labels mean that there's no
confidence interval for example just a
zero or a one in a classification
problem
soft studio labels have a confidence for
each class so for example
0.1 for label 0 or 0.9 for label one
and training on soft suitor labels will
give better performance as as
it approximates the model that the
pseudo labels are produced from
but soft pseudo labels are not always
possible to create or train on
thirdly we can reduce pseudo-label
variants using ensembl
it is crucial for pseudo-labels to be
accurate for a good pseudo-labeling
implementation and in addition to the
techniques mentioned above we can add
ensemble
it does not necessarily have to be
different models for example if we're
doing computer vision we can use tta
test time augmentation
where we can flip an image infer maybe
change the brightness and infer again
or maybe k folds um as a viable option
to ensemble without the hassle feature
engine
of engineering multiple model
architectures
an ensemble of different models to
produce pseudo-labels will result in
significantly better quality pseudo
labels and will pay dividends during
training
i'll talk a bit more about ensemble
models later on
finally we will most likely need to use
multiple
rounds of pseudo labeling for sudo
labeling to be effective it usually
needs to be iterative
not one shot after each iteration we can
add pseudo labels that the model is most
confident on
or even ensemble predictions with the
pseudo labels from the previous
iteration
iterations of pseudo-labels are also
likely to be more robust
and performant than the previous
iteration in fact the state-of-the-art
imagenet model uses many
iterations of pseudo labels up to five
it is worth noting that when using
multiple rounds of pseudo-labeling
we must initialize the model weights
after each round so you cannot simply
use the same model to train on pseudo
labels
create sudo labels turn on some labels
again we have to
train on pseudo labels and then create a
new model
initialize from whites from imagenet or
else we would have quite ridiculous
error propagation
in every other respect though pseudo
labels can be treated like normal
labeled training data
for example class balanced data sets
generally perform better
or we can use class balancing like smote
synthetic
minority over sampling techniques and
the model will be made more robust
through augmentations and dropout
pseudo-labels benefit especially from
augmentations drop out in stochastic
depth
since they allow the model to be more
robust than the model that initially
produced them
which was especially which is especially
important during self training
uh validation is another common trap uh
in kegel you may overtune to the
leaderboard or in the real world
you may overtune to your validation data
i'm not sure if this is used too much
outside of kaggle but in kaggle most
validation is done with k-folds
k-folds is robust along with being very
easy to incorporate into pseudo-labeling
here's the gist of what k-folds is
without pseudo-labeling
first we shuffle the data set randomly
next we split the data set into k
groups usually this is about four to ten
groups now for each group
we take it out and do not train on it it
is our test set
we take the remaining groups and train a
model on them finally
we evaluate the model on the withheld
test set we can repeat this for k-folds
which is where the name comes from
this validation is so effective because
it allows us to train on our entire data
set
yet have extremely effective and
unbalanced validation
there are multiple ways we can use sudo
labels alongside k-fold
the most obvious way is to simply train
a model for each fold and then ensemble
their prediction into one set of
reliable pseudo labels
however this is a slightly leaky
approach if we decide to validate our
model and pseudolabels
then the evaluation data comes from the
predictions from our model
therefore it would be too optimistic and
the cross-validation would be
unrealistic we can see this more clearly
in the graphic
we for each fold we have a single fold
of pseudolabels that the model already
trained on
therefore the pseudo-labels produced for
validation would be higher quality than
any realistic test data
another option is to train each fold and
then evaluate the pseudo-labels
separately and
train on the pseudo-labels separately
then each fold can be trained on its own
pseudo labels
and evaluated on the same k-folds test
data afterwards this is a very reliable
non-leaking method to evaluate
pseudo-labels on each fold
however this leaves a lot of performance
on the table instead of ensembling our k
models we're evaluating them
individually so our pseudo labels are
less likely to be accurate
probably noisier and more variant as we
can see in this graphic each fold has
its own
set of unique pseudo labels and so this
method is not leaky at all
nevertheless the evaluation scheme
chosen by most
kegel winners is slightly leaky there
are certain reasons to choose a leaky
validation however
let's say we have four folds per model
these four folds are
quite diverse so it's meaning to on some
meaningful to ensemble them
let's then say we have three model
architectures which is reasonable for a
competition lasting a few months
then we already have 12 model variants
to ensemble for one single set of pseudo
labels
rather than 12 individual lower quality
sets of pseudo labels
this way though the validation is
slightly leaky the benefits of an
ensemble of many diverse models
producing pseudo labels together
greatly outweighs the importance of
having a single more correlated
cross-validation
it's also possible to use the non-leaky
cross-validation to evaluate models
then train the final approach with a
slightly slightly leaky cross validation
as with most machine learning
applications depending on data
there are many hyper parameters to
adjust and many schemes that may or may
not work
we can make cross-validation less
optimistic by excluding pseudo-labels
from the validation folds
for example we can get the labels run
the k-fold on only the original
labeled data with real labels and add
the labels to train exactly at training
time
this way our cross-validation isn't
biased by easy and artificially
noiseless targets that were produced by
another model
we could also try adding some noise to
the pseudo-labels for example
randomly flipping labels as in the data
generation process
as another way to combat overfitting and
create a more reliable cross-validation
there's a ton to experiment with when it
comes to pseudo labels and there isn't
really one correct formula
now that we've discussed some of the
main applications of pseudo sorry
main elements of pseudolabels and their
implementations
i'll go through some applications
firstly we will explore some of the
solutions of a recent kegel competition
for those who don't know kegel is a data
science community organized by google
we have competitions with a prize pool
of up to one million dollars and anyone
on the internet can participate
the competitions work this way
individuals submit models which are
evaluated on a public test set
which we can see whenever a submission
finishes and a private test set
the final score of the competition and
released at the end
we get to pick two final submissions to
run on private test set and the better
score is the one at the end of the
competition
however there's a few tricks usually the
training set is relatively small and
there are commonly some tricks in the
test set
this particular competition was called
global wheat detection made by the
university of saskatchewan
um this used computer vision
specifically
object detection to identify wheat head
size
and shape from an image to work with we
had about three
000 train images around 1700 public test
images
and 800 private test images so this was
quite a small data set for object
detection
the trick with this competition was that
there was a new location in the private
test set with different variants of
wheat
for example the train test set used
wheat from saskatchewan in great britain
while the private test had some wheat
coming from japan
with this and the large test set
pseudo-labeling was a great help
i got 73 out of 2204
participants earning a silver medal uh i
wanted to share a few of my experiences
and i joined only two weeks before
before the end and the competition had
started two months prior
as a result unlike the vast majority of
participants and previous keggle winners
i did not have time to ensemble i only
had time to train one top performing
model
and optimize it with a few of the
techniques i've talked about
i used yolo v4 which is an object
detection model along with augmentations
such as cut mix
where parts of an image are cut out and
pasted into a different image
hue brightness contrast rotations
horizontal vertical flips and mosaic
so the model baseline performs around
0.69 intersection over union
on the public leaderboard higher is
better which was somewhere near the
middle of the leaderboard around a
thousandth place
so this exact same model earned uh
up to 22nd place on the private
leaderboard so there's a few steps to
improve this model
firstly adding test time augmentation or
tta
this means that the model infers on the
same image multiple times but with
augmentations performed
so for example as i said we would infer
once on the image we'd rotate it
maybe change brightness and then infer
again on it and so
this would give us some better accuracy
this way we had multiple images per
output that we can ensemble
then we used weighted boxes fusion to
ensemble these outputs
with this tta model we have a score of
about 0.7115 intersection over union
on the public leader board with the
exact same model so this placed around
300th place on the private leaderboard
finally with tta inference to
pseudolabeling and adding out a fold
we got a score of 0.7406 on the public
leader board
or 0.6225 on the private leaderboard so
this is an improvement of 4
purely with um self training which
practically was just copy and pasting
some
inference code and some training code
and so this would have boosted us to
36th place
and finally if we added pre-training
i did this in late submissions um we
would have scored 0.7562 on the public
leaderboard
64th place and 22nd place on the private
leaderboard
so this is where we would first train on
the pseudo-labels
and then we would fine-tune other label
data so essentially with only this one
model
we improved five percent by adding
pre-training boosting from 327th place
to a possible 22nd place
all the notebooks used to train these
models are referenced in the github
link and open sourced if anyone's
interested though they're quite verbose
however this is far from the only
application in kaggle competitions
and these are just a few recent
competitions in the past six months i
picked out
and there's a wide wide variety of
competition of competitions in which
these were applied
from our mrna sequence prediction in the
open vaccine competition
in which first second and third all used
pseudo labelings
to tabular competitions such as
harvard's method of action prediction
in which the first place used
pseudo-labeling as well as the fifth
place
to trends neural imaging to nlp
in the tweet sentiment classification
and of course computer vision
and the tg assault identification
challenge which was a
segmentation problem and global weak
detection which was a
object detection challenge finally let's
talk about a real world example
of how this was pseudo labeling was used
to make a record-breaking model
this model was the previous state of the
air on imagenet until two months ago
imagenet is a data set of 14 million
hand-labeled images from 1000 classes
designed to be a comprehensive
evaluation metric
this model is currently tied for number
one and is called efficient l2 noisy
student
the architecture is identical to the
original efficient paper from 2019
but performs four percent better in top
on accuracy and 1.6 percent better in
top five accuracy
purely from pseudo labeling noisy
student achieves this through a novel
approach to pseudo-labeling
here's an extract from the paper noisy
student training extends the idea
of self-training and distillation with
the use of equal or largers
student models and noise added to
student during training
on imagenet we first train an efficient
net model with labeled images and use it
as a teacher to generate pseudo labels
for 300 million
unlabeled images we then train a larger
efficient
as a student model on the combination of
labeled and pseudo-labeled images
we iterate in this process by letting
back the student as a teacher
during the learning as a student we
inject noise such as dropout stochastic
depth run dogment
to the student so that the student
generalizes better than the teacher
end quote to put this into planar
english they first use a small model
efficient at b7 which is trained on the
label data then this model is turned
into the teacher
used to infer on the 300 million images
and then
produces pseudo labels again combined
with image
net label data to train the next largest
model an efficient l0
then the l0 turns into the teacher
teaches an l1 and this is iterated upon
5 times through augmentations and noise
the student model actually improves on
the teacher
techniques used include stochastic depth
where layers are dropped and the others
are boosted as a
shortcut and this was introduced with
the residual networks paper a few years
ago
dropout and random image augmentation
this way the student model is not only
larger and wider than the original
teacher model containing more data but
also more generalized due to the noise
the resulting model is more robust
performing not only better on imagenet
but also against
adversarial opponents we can see in
imaging a
c and p that these images that are
barely able for us to detect
sorry about that
my apologies um imagenet acmp
for images that we can barely even see
um it performs much better than the
previous
state-of-the-art efficient net this
performance is not really unique to the
data set it's trained on either
an additional uh sorry an identical data
set was used to train big transfer
vit-l on this table with 928 million
parameters more than double that of
efficient l2
yet it still only achieves 87.5 accuracy
without this pre-training
and soft pseudo-labeling scheme a few
other techniques are used that i
mentioned
the inference of certain labels uses tta
and a quote from the paper mentioned
this way the student is forced to
approximate what is essentially an
ensemble
in addition the data since the data set
isn't balanced uh synthetic minority
oversampling is used
so for example if we have a lot of one
class we would
over sample the least common class and
then undersample the
most common class um
finally to end off i have a bit of a
minimal example in a notebook
at this link on screen bitch.ly slash pi
notebook or yeah so this is a very
minimal example trained on mnist dataset
and tensorflow
exploring some of the three methods i've
discussed today self training
simultaneous training and pre-training
the cross-validation is just
simple train test split and there's no
augmentations
the train set of mnist is actually
double the size of the test set so this
really isn't an ideal application but i
thought this would be a nice way to
simply demonstrate the code so we first
have some basic data loading
and we define our model so we first
train our student labeling baseline
which performs about 99
on the mnus test set
um we can then try self training so we
first load the weights of the baseline
model and then we produce pseudo labels
by predicting on the test set
and then converting them then we can
fine tune on the test set
and finally we get an accuracy of about
99.01
sorry 99.1 percent accuracy so a very
small improvement but still a tangible
improvement
and then in simultaneous training we
first sued a label so we
load the previous baseline model and
then we
combine all the test data and the train
data the
together and then we train on it and the
accuracy is
identical to the original baseline
finally we can use pre-training again we
produce our pseudo labels
and then we first train only on
pseudolabels
and then we can fine tune on the label
data and this gives us
a larger boost 99.1 percent accuracy
and so yeah this is just a really
minimal code example
in which just with i guess ten lines of
code we can switch from
uh no sudo labeling to self training to
simultaneous training to pre-training
and the final difference between
pseudo-labeling and self-training is
0.06 percent simultaneous training is
actually a bit worse
and then pre-training is about 0.04
percent better
extremely thin margins but again this is
on mnist far from an identical
sorry an ideal application and in
addition
we're already so close to 100 accuracy
it's difficult to improve but yeah just
a very basic code baseline um
yeah thank you for all for attending my
talk and sticking around till the end
and i hope i introduced the versatility
and power of sudo labeling
i am looking for paid or unpaid remote
internships in alberta canada or remote
during the winter of 2020 or summer 2021
please email me at s zhang3
athabasca.edu or message me on linkedin
and i'd be happy to send over my resume
you can connect with me on linkedin
kegel or github at
stanleyjz thanks again
stay safe and happy holidays thank you
stanley for your presentation
and we already have some uh questions in
the chat
let's see first one was for mon on where
will you not suggest using pseudolabels
false negatives are sometimes lethal
yeah
so pseudo labeling
really accentuates a big class imbalance
so if you have a huge class imbalance
it's
quite difficult to find a suitable um
pseudo-labeling implementation um
what else that's all i can think of on
the top of my head
but definitely class imbalance and also
you likely won't see any balance
like you won't likely see any
improvement if there's not a huge
difference in the training
test sets or if the train sets larger
than the test set generally
and then andy was wondering if pseudo
labeling and semi semi-supervised
learning in general
can even work efficiently on large-scale
projects such as detecting human
trafficking
yeah i think large-scale projects is
somewhere this benefits a lot but
maybe not human trafficking in
particular because it sounds like
that's not really a problem of labeling
the data which is really what
semi-supervised learning is meant for
human trafficking sounds like something
which would just we would just be
limited by data in general
right so maybe not the best application
but yeah just large scale projects would
be great for example the facebook
um data set of over 300 million images
was a really great example of pseudo
labeling
and then ted just had a quick question
about for the global weak detection
model
what was the unlabeled data used for it
was it images or was it something else
yeah so um actually we can go back to
this
um share screen yeah so
global weed detection was just image um
object detection
so it would just give us an additional i
guess 2000 images
which we can then pseudo-label these are
actually pseudo-labeled images so we can
just pseudo-label them and we can train
on them
additionally if that answers the
question
just additional images to train on yeah
i think that's really all the questions
people had
i have a quick question if i can jump in
um
stan lee great talk definitely learned a
lot in this short amount of time so
well done i have a question for you
around
how you perceive any type of like
ethical challenges that comes with
pseudo-labeling
i think for perspective so for instance
if the labels you have
um are then used to train on a data set
where there could have been
some systematic reason why the labels
don't exist
um do you think that that would cause
some sort of uh introduced bias to the
model
i'm coming from like a healthcare
perspective so i'm curious on like
how you've thought about like ethical
challenges or bias based challenges
yeah definitely um i'm not particularly
or not at all an expert on bias or
anything like that
i mainly just do competitions on kegel
or freelancing work
so i'm not really too familiar with the
bias but definitely it
is a very real possibility that if there
was some real reason that the
that some data was not labeled then yeah
i do see some bias
there
yeah sorry i can't really answer that
question too well no no i think this is
like
it's always evolving questions i think
this is awesome gives me a lot more to
think about i think uh moving forward
from here so definitely appreciate it
yeah my pleasure
were there any other questions from the
audience
i guess that's a wrap thank you so much
you for
this presentation and
going to move on to harini
we'll have her share her screen
awesome um
okay can everyone see my screen
i see it uh awesome
uh yeah so uh hello everyone uh my name
is harini tannen
i'm a data scientist at capsulate
it's a cyber security company based in
new york city and it basically
provides protection for linux enterprise
infrastructure
so my java file generally includes you
know all kinds of anomaly detection
and i generally work with data sets uh
you know
systems related data sets like you know
process or network data or you know
file paths and all that so um
that is a very quick introduction of
what i do
and today's topic is um topic modeling
for
uh data discovery we're going to see a
cyber security use case
um actually stanley's talk was great uh
was it was an awesome foundation for
what
we're going to see right now because
topic modeling is
an unsupervised nlp approach right
so um yeah so a very quick
introduction on what kind of
applied ml you see in cyber security
it can be basically broadly classified
into two classes
either you're going to be working in
models that are defending against
malicious activity or you're going to be
working
um you know aiding the ethical hacking
uh infrastructure and systems you know
aiding the attack mechanisms
so when you're defending against uh
malicious activity
some of the examples of what kind of
models uh we'd be doing
those are like you know learning and
detecting very very specific
kinds of attacks like right so there are
various exploits being
released out there um i work
specifically
with the limits um related exploits so
you know
um uh you're detecting specific
kinds of attacks that's one kind of work
you generally do the other one is user
behavior analysis
um like you know studying the user
behavior or a developer behavior in you
know in linux
in linux clusters and um
developing models uh specifically for
detecting the anomalies their anomalous
activity there
or network analysis this you this you
see a lot of
uh examples out there you know detecting
dga
and all kinds of network data that you
can use to
[Music]
for a normal extraction so that's one
kind of um
use case when you're aiding when when
ml is used for you know aiding ethical
hacking right you're basically doing
that to strengthen to harden your
systems so when you do that some of the
use cases include you know um
adversarial models
to you know circumvent existing
detections those could be ml detections
those could be
you know deterministic detections uh
anything you're basically working to
um uh basically working on attack models
right and then uh data poisoning how you
can
uh circumvent existing ml models uh
by uh introducing uh some way by
some way by poisoning the data by
poisoning the training data or something
uh that's an interesting field what we
are going to see today is
uh relevant to the third point that has
been highlighted which is
reconnaissance activity to capture
leaked
uh credentials so uh you basically
uh try and collect data try and collect
data and do analysis
to figure out you know can you figure
find any uh leaked passwords and lead
credentials
this is generally done by you know
something called red teams
um so in in security teams in general
you have two
uh in penetration testing teams right
you have two kinds of teams
uh red team is the the ethical hacking
group
and blue team is the one that's going to
uh
defend against um the red teams right so
they
they simulate a lot of attack scenarios
to make sure your um uh
your company's infrastructure your
company's applications everything is
secure
so um red team is basically
a group of physical digital hackers
right so they do offensive security they
do ethical hacking
um exploiting vulnerabilities
penetration testing
uh black box testing uh you know social
engineering that's
yeah and um all all the
attack stuff and the blue team is the
one that defends that
blue team is the one that builds the
defense mechanisms
uh so you know uh their
their uh work profile generally includes
defensive security infrastructure
protection
damage control incident response uh
analyzing all kinds of you know threat
um threat detection threat hunting
digital forensics and all that
so um what we are going to see today is
a methodology that would
uh help speed up uh the data analysis
part
for the red teams right so remember we
talked about reconnaissance right we
want to
go through huge uh data sets to figure
to find out interesting data points like
you know
leaked passwords or credentials or codes
or whatever is there in like huge
corpus of data so the first step
for a teams is information gathering
uh so they consist of ethical hackers as
we saw before
they evaluate system security in an
objective manner
so once a target is set right meaning
once they identify a specific
part of the infrastructure or specific
application to attack
the first step that they want to do is
gather information on their attack
target
right so that information could be
anything could be anything depending on
what kind of
company they are um working with right
so it could be
the names and phone numbers and you know
email addresses
and all that information um within that
organization
it could be social media accounts it
could be what kind of
thoughts are open uh where can you start
getting data what kind of domain names
ip addresses that you see
in the traffic in the network traffic
right and
uh what kind of insecure files programs
and
is there any um servers configurations
that you can
exploit and uh they look for
um passwords leak passwords and
credentials that's
the very first easiest step to
get into systems and applications
without even doing
anything right so um
now we have a messy log data set so
they get their hands on huge number of
logs it could be from
any number of systems right it could be
from various system domes
most of them are unstructured data right
so um it's generally a problem of big
data for them so
where do you start um this is one of the
most time consuming tasks uh
for red team uh we actually started this
project
uh after a red team member came to us
saying
do you have any uh ml uh solution that
you can apply
that would speed up this process right
so
um yeah their main goal was to recover
leaked passwords
um uh also you know we can argue that
you know you can simply use
filter using simple tools like grip or
something
to figure out um whether you have useful
data but
what do you grip on you you have this
huge corpus of data
and you um don't know where to start
with
so um it's a classic nlp problem
uh where we have unstructured data we
have data from
multiple sources we don't know where to
start with
there's obviously no labels and there's
a lot of time
there's no context a red team suddenly
jumps in
and then you you get hold of this data
there's not a lot of context or you have
to spend time to learn that right
so um so
this project is the one that introduced
me to topic modeling so
i started um i i started exploring this
only after knowing
okay this is the problem what are the
ways to solve it right
so um topic modeling was
very interesting approach and i tried it
and surprisingly we could find
a lot more leak credentials than
what the red team member could find
manually so topic modeling is a
statistical
um technique for discovering topics
right like
clustered topics that occur in a
collection of documents
uh you it basically derives hidden
patterns exhibited by
uh text corpus it's it's basically a
form of uh
document clustering right so uh
where do you generally uh see topic
modeling
uh if you simply google topic modeling
the first thing that would come up is
you know
a new york times example of using uh to
boost their user article
uh recommendation engines um you have
tons of examples on that
um you know where they're clustering
all the news articles into um you know
known topics
like these are sports this is politics
this is weather uh et cetera
and then you see uh recruitment
industries extract latin features
of uh job descriptions and map them to
the right candidates
um in marketing uh you see clustering
the social media profiles
a lot of it um is used uh for you know
targeted marketing
um for the specific products right
the place where um it's actually a big
deal and i did not know this before
uh before specifically googling for it
is it's used in search engine
optimization
google uh actually confirmed that they
are using topic modeling to
assist their um ranking algorithm
and you know once the slide is shared
there's the link
to the blog post from google and there's
another paper
there stating different
other applications of topic modeling
yeah so the common techniques
used for topic modeling is
latin semantic analysis uh probable
probabilistic latin semantic analysis
and latent direct allocation
uh lsa is simply you know it finds a
low dimension representation of
documents uh and words
um plsa the probabilistic latent
semantic analysis
is instead of using matrices
it uses a probabilistic method right lda
which we are going to see today
and which is probably the most used
one is simply a generalized form of plsa
but
uh by changing the document index to a
dilect uh prior
uh okay so let's see
the intuition behind lda we will not be
going into a lot of uh
the algorithm specific as to how it
actually works
uh you you have tons of uh literature on
that
uh if you want to learn about um
lda the mechanism how the the mechanic
mechanics work behind
the algorithm and um
yeah the the theory behind it but to
understand the the general intuition
behind lda
each document is considered as a
collection of topics
in a certain proportion and each topic
is a collection of keywords in a certain
proportion so basically you want to find
the dominant topic in each dominant
keywords in each topic
that's the the goal of this right so
once the number of
uh topics is given to the algorithm uh
here that
cannot be found automatically we have to
give it so we'll we'll also see how to
figure out what's the optimum number of
topics uh to give right so once the
number of topics is given
uh it rearranges the topics distribution
within the documents and keyword
distribution
within the documents and the keyword
distribution within the topics
uh so it's a topic document matrix
and a keyword topic matrix right to
obtain a good composition of
topic keywords distribution um the
basically it backtracks and tries to
figure out the topics which would create
those documents
uh in the first place uh you understand
it i think
yeah uh easier here so it's a matrix
factorization technique uh if you see
uh in the um the visualization
here right any corpus is represented as
a document term matrix here
so in the first matrix here this shows
the corpus of
n documents uh you know d1 d2
d3 with a vocabulary of m words
right and then lda converts this
document term matrix
into two lower dimensional matrices m1
and m2
and then in the next two visualizations
uh
next two matrices that you see uh m1 is
a document topic matrix with dimension
n and k m2 is a topic term matrix
with dimension k and m and n is the
number of documents k is the number of
topics and msc vocabulary size
um this could be
um confusing if we if
there's a suddenly put before you but i
promise you if you
go through the the whole mechanics of
how it works um
it's simple to understand so uh
this is just to get an um introduction
before
going to the actual application and the
code right
so uh for every topic two probabilities
are calculated right
the first one is the proportion of words
in a document that are currently
assigned to a topic
the second one is the proportion of
assignments to topic
over all documents that come from this
word
so uh finally the current topic word
assignment is updated with the new topic
this is done in nitration right uh
with the probability product of p1 and
p2 so once you iterate over this
multiple times
uh the model finally reaches the
convergence point
and the steady state is achieved when
there is a you know a good document
topic or topic term distribution
well you can change it based on you know
once you have
seen the topics and it's coherent
if it makes sense um you know it kind of
works
so okay now let's get to the actual
application uh so we got hold off this
nation state
hackers um hard drives um
this is a real scenario a red team
member came to us with
the the heart discrimination state
hacker and i was given access to
uh the system logs in a single hard
drive um
for analysis right so uh the challenge
was
um the the red team they spent
a lot of time to filter a few hundred
passwords so uh they were like
can you find out more than us and can
you do that in a fraction of time that
um
which we did right so um
okay after a few slides we will look at
the code
uh but i um we have changed the data set
because we um um we cannot use the real
data
that's confidential and we don't have
permission to
um send it out but the
the code remains the same i simply
change the data set
uh later i'll show you the
visualizations from the real data set by
blacking out the
passwords and stuff but uh the
the methodology is the same just the
data is different
right so step by step we will go through
the normal
preprocessing that we do for any nlp
uh project right so we prepare the stop
words
we remove the unnecessary characters we
tokenize sentences
um and limit eyes and then once we
finish the pre-processing will create a
dictionary and corpus to be used
for topic modeling right the stopwatch
and everything would be slightly
different
from what we normally do with a normal
english
corpus because your system corpus is
going to be different
your stop words for say uh if my data
set
is from linux shell right my
uh vocabulary is going to be different
it's going to be whatever
shell commands that you type if your
data set is going to be you know network
related data your software is going to
be different for that so you can simply
change
uh based on whatever kind of corpus you
have right then you create the model and
then
you have something called coherence
course which you can use to figure out
what's your optimum
number of topics for your corpus
right and then we do the model selection
we figure out what's the dominant topic
in each document
and uh most representative sentence for
each topic
it's optional you figure out uh you you
visualize the word cloud you visualize
t-sne clustering
you visualize the model we'll see all
this later
so um yeah let me
um
send the link
so yeah
i can send you the link of this
to the okay i don't think i can access
the
chat for some reason when i'm sharing
okay you might have to unshare and then
put it in okay yeah okay i just got it i
think you should be able to
see this notebook uh
yeah so we saw
what a topic is and what lda is and
everything
right so we will go to what we are doing
uh in this notebook right so
uh obviously i was not able to share the
real data so what i've done
is uh we have a tcp dump data
uh it's it's a network data set from a
cyber security
uh defense competition where the teams
were physically looked co-located in the
same building
each team was given physically identical
computer configurations
throughout the competition the teams had
to
ensure that the systems supply the
specified services while
under attack so there was a voluntary
team that was uh
doing the attack um and in addition the
teams had to satisfy
periodic injects that simulate you know
business activities that
looked real like in real world right so
uh
also note this is a huge data set so if
you
uh i tried bringing the whole data set
into collab
and it kind of crashed so um
maybe uh try this in your own
environment or maybe reduce the data set
size um so our task this also contains
passwords this may look trivial i mean
for this data uh but um
in real world where you don't know
whether you have passwords or anything
out there uh it would be interesting but
this is a uh effect
uh so useful use case to uh replicate
the same experiment
right so we are going to build a
lda model and uh let's see so
uh so this is basically so yeah here if
you see uh how to
so you download the data set from this
link here
uh it would be a pcapp dataset dot pcapp
right so the easiest way
um i found was just uh open the data set
in wireshark
uh it's a network application and then
you can export it as csv
uh for the purposes of running this
notebook i randomly
took like hundred thousand um data
points
uh to run this faster right
so uh we are going to use jensem uh
for the lda model uh right so the the
raw data
looked like this right you have the
service the destination the
the what's the protocol and then you
have the actual information
that you want to look at uh so
uh here you have the pre-processing
steps
uh the pre-processing steps uh go
through you know
uh the normal um steps here like you
know using the stop words
um so so this assumes that you are um
familiar with the the basics of um nlp
right the pre-processing and stuff
if not i think this uh should give you
a start like a jump start to you know uh
just start googling like what stop words
what's lemmatization what's everything
and
they should give you um uh jump start i
think so
um just a quick um intro stop words are
like you know
common words on a corpus that you don't
want like uh that
are of little value for the documents um
matching so
uh also other than english language um
uh consider domain specific stop words
like it could be different for linux
data set it could be different for
network data set and all that
um limitization uh we're doing here
that is grouping together you know
different inflected forms of a word so
they can be analyzed as a single item
right it brings context to the words
uh it links words with similar meaning
to one word for example
better and good it will have the same
context
corpora corpus has the same context
rocks rock
has the same context right so um
those kinds of pre-processing uh you
would do
and um yeah you're you're creating the
bigrams and thai grounds and all that
so once that's done you have your corpus
ready right so once you have the corpus
ready
uh let's build the model so um
for building the model while building
the model uh
we are actually going to build multiple
models and calculate
coherence uh value so
to give you a quick intro of what
coherence value means
you basically evaluate a topic model
using coherence value it assures the
um quality of the learned topics right
whether it's coherent or it just
you know it simply doesn't make sense so
uh it does that by measuring the
relative distance between words within a
topic
so higher the score uh better model
right so we did that
and then we are computing the coherence
values the the code everything is here
um
isn't here you can you know test it out
um and then we are plotting the
coherence values for
all the different models that we have
calculated with different number of
topics
uh obviously it's spiking the most for
um
five number of topics right uh doesn't
necessarily mean
that is the best model that you have so
you can probably experiment it with you
know say
experiment with five and then experiment
with
uh and then see whether uh
uh dividing that into you know more
number of topics maybe
could give you um from a human
introspection that you know that's a
better topic so
yeah so here for uh just for experiment
purposes i've just taken the
um highest coherence values model
um right and um
i'm looking at the top uh
words um the keywords in that uh
in that model right for each topic
and then you have that and then you see
what's the dominant topic
in each document and the topic weight
right and then you see for each uh
topic you have what are the keywords
that the model has
produced and then
you see the uh word term uh
for the topics uh you can see here
it's uh coherent enough
like you can see here topic one has you
know uh
pass it has user somewhere uh it would
be clearer here i think
yeah uh topic one has a
pass that's that could be password right
and
it um it has user it has membership it
has
um yeah uh unknown
so error so that could be authentication
stuff
related so uh okay no no now we see
this is an interesting topic that i
would like to explore
so let's go and explore further so
so given a huge corpus of data where you
simply don't
know what um what's the context behind
it this is a very useful
way to um in an unsupervised way simply
cluster them into different uh groups
right into different topics
now uh another way to visualize this
and then um classified them is using
t-sne right t-sne
is a dimensional reduction technique uh
you'd be familiar with the pca the
principal company analysis right that's
the
linear demand reduction uh technique tc
t-sne similar one it's called t
distributed stochastic neighbor uh
embedding
it's a tool to again similar to pca
visualize high dimensional data i use it
a lot uh especially in
um infosec it's very useful
it's very important to be
as for a model to be as explainable as
possible right
like if you have a a result people will
definitely ask you why do you have this
why why do you think this data point is
neighbor to that data point so
it's all so teasing is a very very
useful tool
it maps multi-dimensional data to two or
more dimensions
uh suitable for human observation and
converts similarities between data
points to
join probabilities right so um
you can uh you know classified by
different topics and then
uh later in the slides i'll show you the
actual t-sne
of the hacker data set that that which
is very interesting
and then you use um pi lda with
um library which is a wrap a python
wrapper over um ldavies which is a very
uh i think well known or library uh
which you can
you know visualize it um
and then go and filter for you know uh
which
topic you want so this is a useful um
visualization too so um
here it's very simplistically it gives
the um
passwords but in real data but it
actually makes sense that here also
it proves the uh or hypothesis that you
know all the passwords are
grouped into one uh topic and then you
you know how much however big it is
you've just find all
whatever credentials um
that are leaked right so okay
so let's go back to
this and
right so this is from the real
hacker data set right you can see
topic three has password save login
cloud backup
access all that blah blah blah which
clearly
shows okay so this is a topic that you
um
could go and look uh more into right and
um topic zero
is you can see you know verify
account verification code
mobile all that okay so this is some
kind of
uh a topic that shows um
[Music]
like you know codes um so that's an
interesting topic to see
so uh topic three exposes the keyword
password so we know that's a good
starting point
um uh here you can see
uh we just go and do the go and look at
that particular thing and you
actually have the real passwords so we
kind of logged it up and
uh the the real link uh to which
the password is used so um
yeah the the one that they took uh a lot
of time to actually go
and finally uh catch it in you know a
specific document
in hundreds of documents uh you get it
basically in few
uh seconds or minutes right
uh topic zero was interesting uh go and
look for verification
and it was for um
wechat i think uh it was all the
verification codes for
uh that particular um application
uh for some reason that was stored so um
yeah so this was the t-sne uh plot for
the
um the hacker data set which was very
interesting because it had a very nice
structure to when you visualize um the
the data right uh so
yeah that is basically it uh hopefully
this will
um uh if you already are familiar with
topic modeling
i think you actually know more than me
um
so and if not i think the shoe this
notebook should give you a jump start
to um uh topic modeling to
not just this data set or any any kind
of data set that you want
and uh yeah hopefully this will also
interest you in um cyber security as the
domain for experimenting
in developing your mo um endorse yeah
all right thank you so much harini so
there were a few questions from the
audience um one of which came from mon
about
why is his cine preferred over umap
in information security uh
i'm actually not sure i have generally
used
t-sne and pca
because pca is pretty fast and then
tasty if you don't have
a large number of features then t-sne
was generally better i have not used
umap so
um i don't have the answer for that but
that's a very good question
to um ponder over
i guess i i generally use pca if
there's a huge feature set and
tasty if otherwise but um
that is interesting and thank you for
bringing it up like i think uh
it's a good question to ponder i mean to
research
and have you i'm not sure whether uh
umap
um uh i mean is uh
the preferred uh i mean these preferred
over umap and infosec i mean
that's really my bias it it could be
completely
a different outside i'm not sure
one other question was have you ever
encountered a false positive
where the learning model says that there
is a correlation between something and
it actually wasn't
oh all the time yeah i mean um
right so one of the biggest challenges
in
um infosec cyber security in general
especially i saw the difference
um from you know how different it is
from the data sets that you generally
use in like you know in your
in your uh academia in your
masters and everything versus uh coming
to the industry
there was simply no labels there was
something on
labels and it was so expensive to
actually get labeled data especially in
cyber security because getting attack
labels is very expensive you either have
a honeypot or something to you know
you have to maintain that to get
attackers in the wilds to come and
attack the system
so you can have label data or uh
your company generally has to spend a
lot to um
actually uh simulate that environment
right
so um when we are so most of my
experiments right from my internship has
always been unsupervised
so uh with that you obviously have
a huge amount of false positives and the
the trick is to
figure out uh the trick is to the trick
is in feature engineering is what i've
seen so far
uh in terms of you know you have all
these security experts
um who know much more than me
as a data scientist in terms of you know
what kind of features you can use
or you can engineer that would make your
model better
but fast positives is one of the biggest
pain point in
cyber security
and also compared to other domains like
you know in
ad tech or somewhere where your model
accuracy you know it could be
uh 90 95 percent and it could go into
production whereas in cyber security the
uh the threshold is really really high
uh it has to be like 99.7 99.8 percent
to
to actually even be considered for uh
production
great i think those are all the
questions in the chat i was wondering if
anyone else in the audience want to
chime in with a question
i have a question harini again another
great talk i think this was
fabulous i learned a lot and again in a
short time
and my question for you uh coming from
like the cyber security space and
i'm just thinking back to even i think
it's last week that the
um fire eye hack that happened based on
like a password
solar winds one two three yes so
to me i'm just like all right simple
passwords and like what are the things
that we need to be doing to kind of
protect that
from my question to you is um from your
perspective
how much do you see kind of machine
learning um
nlp really supporting the cyber security
space
especially as um all this automation
comes into play with like
devops infosec and so there's a lot less
humans and loops so kind of where do you
see things going
on the next few years on the ml and
cyber security space
right it's actually a great question and
um
i have been talking about this like
within my company or within the
infosec community for a while which is
um a mln infosec has not
reached a stage or definitely
lagging behind how much the ml
has progressed in other domains right
and a lot of it
has been because um
[Music]
uh because of a lot of
uh companies studying
um normal blacklist or whitelist smo so
so the the term itself is kind of
tainted uh a little bit
uh as far as uh but having said that
now there's a lot of uh development uh
because of you know awareness being
created in all these um
conferences uh black hat had their first
uh ai nml um
separate section in their uh conference
black hat is
one of the biggest or the most premier
conference that you have in cyber
security it has been running for 20 21
years
um and
i was lucky enough to give a talk
this year this was the first time my
ainmo got added
so a lot of people are talking about it
or talking about you know
um a lot of work is going on in
adversarial mo like
um especially data poisoning and all
that
and how given existing models how can
you circumvent them there's a lot of
work going on in there
and uh one of the biggest um
places where work is going on is for uh
reducing the alert fatigue reducing the
false positives uh even
without um ai animal right uh
one of the biggest uh problems in cyber
security is having false postures even
from
non-stochastic you know deterministic
detections uh
people go through that security analysts
go through that manually which is a pain
so uh which is one of the areas where ml
can help
uh you know in clustering uh clustering
out filtering out all the false
positives
uh which they're working on and so i
think there's a lot of development going
on there
and um yeah
i have been specifically working on you
know um
performance counter related data which
is like you know
has surprisingly never not been
not been researched or touched a lot uh
from ml side like you have
tons of data in terms of what your
system is generating in terms of
performance counters right the intel
counters that are continuously giving
out data
there's so much of data available and
uh not much
research done there especially with the
spectrum meltdown that came out last
year
not last year 2018 i think so
um yeah it's definitely catching up um
people are noticing it um uh obviously
would
love so many more people to come into
cyber security you know and look that as
a uh
domain i mean uh be it in like you know
in college or
uh while we're starting the uh
ml journey right like i never thought i
would get into cyber security but
uh yeah it's a pretty cool feel like if
um yeah you definitely need more people
more ml people there
great is there anyone else with last
thoughts or
last questions
stanley wrote a great talk or any didn't
realize machine learning played such a
large part in cyber security so
i'm glad various people various
attendees here
mentioned learning a bit from both of
your presentations and have expressed
thanks for both of your proper working
presentations as well
so thank you stanley thank you harini
thank you all the attendees for joining
us for this last event of the year
and we'll post links shared tonight on
any additional follow-ups in our slack
channel and paella boston
and please stay posted on pi data
boston's events and meet up
with that i just want to wish everyone
happy holidays
and we hope to see you next year
thank you happy holidays
yeah it is everyone